[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Linc and I'm
Rhett it's time for another conversation
with someone interesting from the
internet and that person this week is
Devin Graham known on the youtubes as
Devin Supertramp I think this guy's the
best outdoor action adventure filmmaker
on YouTube currently he's got over 2
million subscribers if you haven't seen
his videos he's basically filming people
doing insane physical stunts in
beautiful locations around the world and
the videos are intoxicating and they
make me feel good
the videos are intoxicating yeah I mean
the camerawork is amazing it's the
amount of creativity that goes into
these things he's basically everyone's
get a guaranteed feel-good viral video
unless you just don't like fun and you
don't like start physical stuff in
amazingness
now we caught up with Devin at VidCon we
did exchanged some emails with him about
maybe collaborating on something that
didn't involve us risking our lives but
at least this is a step towards that
meeting in person at VidCon recording
this year biscuit just to give you some
context his most popular video with over
37 million views is titled Assassin's
Creed meets parkour in real life now
we'd play a clip for you but it wouldn't
do much you could be some residual music
and sound effects which I mean we could
make those with our mouths but that
would be disappointing also because it
wouldn't actually be from the video yes
I mean it's a parkour dude dressed as
the dude from Assassin's Creed doing his
thing around the city and in costume and
it's just shot in an amazing way I mean
you you've probably seen yeah a lot of
his videos and what his channel you'll
just be overwhelmed yeah he's one of
those guys who when you ask somebody if
they've watched YouTube videos they end
up not realizing that they've seen one
like the human slingshot or the world's
largest rope swing a slip and slide off
of a cliff trike drifting flyboarding I
mean all these amazing physical things
done in these amazing locations a lot of
good-looking people in the video we
actually talked to him about that where
did you find all these good-looking
people that he puts in his videos but
you've you've probably seen one even if
didn't know it because he doesn't he's
not the face of his videos you have to
kind of go to the behind the scenes to
see who he is right not only are the
videos amazing I think what we
discovered in our conversation was that
those videos and the product that he
creates has gotten Deven into some
amazing situations some interesting
relationships so we talked about those I
would say we surface one of the most
surprising backstories that I didn't
didn't see coming in the history of ear
biscuits I mean we do some research but
sometimes we kind of know some things we
want people to talk about but when he
started talking about meeting kim.com in
New Zealand I was like I'm so glad this
is happening and you know I don't want
to give away the whole story but if you
haven't heard because well you'll hear
it in just a few seconds but if you
haven't heard of kim.com I learned about
him I'd heard about him but there was a
whole wired article about I got a
super-rich founder of file sharing
service mega upload there's I'll read
this little clip from Wikipedia about
him
Kim calm face US charges of costing the
entertainment industry five hundred
million dollars through pirated content
uploaded to mega upload his site which
had 150 million registered users
he's vigorously denied the charges and
his attempt fighting the attempt to
extradite him to the United States but
in January 2012 Kim dot-coms mansion
kind of like a compound was raided and
it involves 76 officers and two
helicopters and this is what was
detailed in the wired article but the
thing that I didn't know was that Devin
Supertramp
was almost there for it that's crazy
so you'll find out exactly why he was
almost there for it and his adventures
with Kim comm and also somebody else
that might have tagged along that we
have interviewed before we're gonna find
out about his relationship with one
Lindsey Stirling yeah he helped connect
a few dots that were established but not
connected in our conversation with
Lindsey yes yeah that's another
interesting point to listen out for in
general as you would expect from a guy
who makes some of the most
funniest videos on the Internet's
funnest we had the most funnest ear
biscuit conversation with him sure it is
our ear biscuit with deficit betrayal
[Music]
there's the phenomenon in general
watching YouTube videos and you get
sucked into the YouTube cauldron or I
don't know what people call it different
things but just getting sucked into the
the YouTube loophole what do people call
it warp so I don't know what they call
it but my point is when I watched the
latest Devin Supertramp Channel video
and then it's I'm sucked into an endless
cycle of rewatching other ones and oh
I've seen this one but I gotta watch it
again
especially if I'm a little blue right
like a little down mean like you're
talking about inappropriate things no
meaning if I'm a little sad or depressed
nothing like one of your videos to make
me feel happy and scared at the same
time that's what we do best
we're all about it is that so that's the
weird thing is that is that the
intention to what what feeling do you
want people to have I think for us like
originally when we started the channel I
was I mean essentially was me with a
camera going out having fun with my
friends we saw another YouTube video
people hitting a bike jump like a pond
like getting a jump going into the pond
splashing and we notice it had two
million views and it was shot with an
iPhone so we're like what if I went in
there and did something a little bit
more professional
see what happens show the world
something that not a whole lot of people
had seen put that on YouTube and then it
kind of exploded and took off so for us
everything you had like a red camera no
like a glidecam we had a glidecam and a
Canon t2i
and a canon 5d mark ii that i borrowed
from a friend we didn't even own any of
our own camera equipment at the time so
we're just borrowing it from friends cuz
we were going to I was gonna film school
so I mean I was just going out hanging
out with my friends and they're like
let's just capture this we've seen a lot
of YouTube videos we saw what other
people were doing so we're like let's
see what we can do and then we posted
that video and the where was the pond I
mean you had to get a pond what you want
is you know you had to get a ramp you
had to get guys who could ride a bike
and then
how many feet we said 40 feet because it
sounded crazy but it's probably
realistically 20 30 feet but really the
way it came about is the pond wasn't too
far from my house was like a 20 minute
drive we saw the video we knew where it
was so we did a post on Facebook just
our personal Facebook page because
that's all that existed saying hey we're
doing this video can anyone any BMX
bikers out there that can hit this do
any tricks and then we said the time the
location and then we had maybe 8 or 10
people that actually joined us and then
we spent the whole day filming it so you
didn't know any of the bikers that went
off of your jump personally until they
showed up exactly so it's all through
social media from the get-go and it was
like I didn't have a falling or anything
was just essentially my friends and they
got their friends to come join and then
we spent the whole day and then after we
spend that day I looked at the footage
I'm like this is really cool let's do
this even better so then we actually
spent three days shooting that video to
make it the best it could be and then we
released it and then you watch that you
watch the dailies the first day but I
got to come back two more days
two more days it was like I wanted to
get it perfect it was a little bit
cloudy that day I'm like I want to be a
summer buy video so I rescheduled it we
shot two more days and it was just me
and another friend who was going to film
school that shot that video together we
did that video and then I put it up on
YouTube and then the first day got a
thousand views which I never had a video
that got a thousand views before I was
like so excited about it and then the
next day jumped up to eighty thousand
views and I just remember thinking holy
cow like what's going on here and then
all these companies started contacting
us flip camera which existed that time
it's out of business now they contacted
me was four days later they're like we
just saw this video we want to hire you
to do a nationwide TV commercial with
our flip cameras with the same concept
so all of a sudden I got these huge job
offers from this YouTube video do that I
did do that and then it ended up on TV
so for me was like Olsen I saw this huge
potential I was going to film school at
the time I was three years into it about
to graduate and then I saw all that
happened so I actually dropped out of
film school to pursue YouTube full-time
surely after all that to god he's taken
on a I mean from those humble beginnings
and they weren't really that humble I
mean you put together a pretty amazing
video it's it's gone too
a whole new level I mean look at the the
latest video that you released we're
recording this and it's the the 50 foot
cliff slip-and-slide now I just want to
say personally this scares me a little
bit because I don't even do regular
slip-and-slide anymore haha there became
this point came this point in my life
when I just thought I'm no longer doing
that Hey
because I'm almost the length of the
slip and slide the typical slip and
slide that my kids will use you know I'm
like halfway there when I lay down right
the second of all I'm afraid I'm gonna
injure something but this let me slide
it was like how many feet long and then
how many feet and we were yo is 50 feet
off of a cliff right once you left the
slip and slide 50 feet straight down
until water insane so where was this
first of all and hell I mean how do you
even set this up to where you can do it
without being arrested well half the
things we do are technically illegal so
actually that's the truth of the matter
and I mean we go in it is a small we
call guerrilla filmmaking so we're a
small crew it's not like a professional
Hollywood crew we have all these people
otherwise we would have got stopped
right away but we shot this at Lake
Powell and it's actually illegal to
cliff jump so I'm not sure if we want
this people that are listening this but
this is the truth this is the uncut
unedited version but yeah you can only
John Powell Lake Powell which is in Utah
which is I mean essentially that's three
hours from where we're based out of so
just a short little drive and yeah we
just essentially decided to do that you
can only jump 20 feet there legally so
we were doing 50 feet so we were already
breaking a couple rules and but we did
it kind of out in the middle of nowhere
so there wasn't anyone that was gonna
stop us and that's essentially kind of
how it went down but I was like 50 feet
sliding down and then 50 feet flying off
of a cliff but how where does the idea
come from the the inception of the thing
yeah I think with all the videos that we
do we try and take little kid ideas and
put a grown-up twist on it so and
because people connect with that stuff
everyone's done a slip and slide you
know like everyone's done a slip inside
them generally speaking so it's like
what can we do to basically put a macho
guy twist on it so that's kind of how a
lot of these ideas come from like
for example our rope swinging video this
one of our most watched videos
everyone's done a rope swing so where's
like what can we do to make it the next
step so let's make it 400 foot rope
swing you know so it's just like it the
world's largest world's largest rope
sink so it's always trying to up the
ante show it in a new way but people can
connect with that because everyone sent
a rope swing everyone's done a slip and
slide okay so you think okay
slip and slide got it I'm gonna put it
on the side of a cliff there's one three
hours away not really legal but it's
really isolated so no one will ever know
and you're not coming in on a helicopter
you're like hiking and you're like yeah
that one we actually took like a
houseboat so we drove out there and then
we shot all day for a couple days with a
bunch of our friends so essentially
that's how it goes down but you know
when you're jumping off of a 50-foot
cliff how do you you you obviously
you're doing this in a place where some
money's probably done this before but
it's not like this is the designated
jumping area you've got to kind of know
like no one's gonna hit the bottom right
so how does how do you work that stuff
out how do you know how deeper these
people are gonna go and we know that
they're not gonna hit a rock and yeah no
great question it's like to come up with
essentially the concept so you figured
out the concept and then a couple of our
friends that do all the videos with us
we sent them out a couple days early
because there's no designated spot this
is where you do the 50-foot you know
slip and slide there's no sign there's
no it's not an amusement park so they
went out and they spent literally two
days driving around Lake Powell trying
to find a location that would actually
work when who are these people stunt
people just Facebook friends essentially
they're just people that I've met as
we've been doing YouTube videos like
this guy in particular I was at a
restaurant he stopped me he's like hey I
saw that you did this video we do a rope
swing he showed me on his phone a rope
swing that they had done it was the arch
one and I was like I saw that I was like
I would love to do that so we did that
together and we just became friends so
essentially as we create videos we make
friends and then essentially now our
fans inspire our ideas we're constantly
getting submissions saying hey you guys
should do this you guys should do this
so we're seeing other ideas from our
fans and then we're going out there and
creating it on a much higher end level
you got two guys who now work for you
mmm-hmm they location location scouted
yeah they're also cliff divers they're
everything I mean they do their ropes in
with us anything that requires any kind
of dangerous stunts these guys do and I
mean bona fide stunt guys you can call
whatever you want all right
but they don't they're not like movie
stunt guy not at all like it's funny
like the main guy he was studying to
become a lawyer
the pelant guy with the blond high with
the blond hair like every time I call
him when I first started working with
him he was always in the library
studying for the bar exam this is not
just like some lifelong friend this is a
guy was like I'll do this yeah exactly
oh he's becoming old Rises and now he's
become the star so it's worked out great
but he hasn't got any choice his name's
Creighton Curtin Bear did this guy were
referring to he's a blond hair guy he
got really famous when we did her video
where he pushed his girlfriend off of
the rope swing and she broke up with him
as he was falling or she was falling and
that's true completely true now she said
I'm breaking up with you but they
actually didn't break up at that time
they broke up like two or three months
later a different story say that for a
different day but that was all part of
the process yeah it was all part of the
process and then we just became friends
as we worked together and I mean for me
that's what I love about what we do with
YouTube is about finding passionate
people in their fields and then working
with them and creating cool things
well passionate is one way to describe
them I can think of another word to
describe them
it's called crazy or stupid or this or
that
if it's a little harsh but crazy in the
most endearing way right oh for sure
well I you know you're cut you've kind
of answered the question in terms of you
know where you where these people come
from you've got a couple of look at the
core guys who are gonna kind of always
be involved but then every once in a
while it seems like you find a group of
people or a person who does something
amazing and you're like okay I can put
the Devin Supertramp slant on that I can
capture that in the way that only you
are capturing those kinds of things now
for sure let's let's talk about another
one that world's largest rope swing
which you've talked about a little bit
you said this that's the guy just coming
up to you and showing the video on his
phone so they had figured out how to tie
a rope to the top of one of these
unbelievably two large arches in like
what a Utah National Park
know so was it a national park so
actually there's nothing illegal about
that video which you think there was
something but it was on public domain
land where anyone could go out there um
it's still legal now they actually sent
that video because I got so much
traction so many people started going
there they have a sign that says due to
a popular video showing a rope swing be
very cautious because if you don't know
what you're doing this can be very
dangerous all right yeah which is is
that so that rocks swing it's a 200-foot
rope swing itself so Rope the rope it is
200 so maybe 240 feet ish total but
they're swinging 200 feet no okay so
you've got these guys who've done this
before
they have conceivably figured out the
physics involved but I mean you know you
never know I mean these guys could just
be it could be me and link showing you
this video right so how do you gain a
sense of alright these guys are legit no
one's going to die and okay we can move
forward with this like what I always
kind of just assume when I look at
something like that light on there must
be some some somebody is like really
analyzing all this to make sure that
it's going to be you know totally legit
and safe right now for sure and it's
like the guys that we're using they're
not guys we just randomly pick off the
streets like this guy was studying to be
a lawyer like the guy that actually did
like the calculations to make sure it
was safe like he's a mathematician and
then basically we go up there they
figured it out on their own okay and
then there's like set of them and
they're all hardcore rock climbers so
they're used to working with those kind
of ropes and they do this like every
weekend so I know they're already
passionate about it I know they have a
good sense of what they're doing and
then once we get up there they spend all
day setting it up like it was a full day
of setting up for the canyon rope swing
and then each one of them checks it
double checks it and then the last
person to or the first person to jump is
the last person to check it so you know
they're double double double checking it
and then before they don't like send a
dummy first no so that's where I'm going
next so after they do all the testing
then they got a two hundred pound bag
they hooked it up to the rope and then
they swung it off just to make sure the
way the rope swung and everything like
it would have been safe and right no no
question it wasn't sure that it doesn't
just go right into the side
I mean the things we do as far as stunts
generally speaking like you're not gonna
get hurt you're gonna lose your life so
and I don't want to have that on my
shoulders no one wants to have that on
their shoulder so we do all the testing
possible and I mean there's always
different variables but generally
speaking we make sure it's as safe as
possible for everyone there but they're
kind of handling that aspect of it the
people who have experienced with the
specific stunt I'll call it whereas I
would imagine most of your time and
energy is how do I capture this in the
way that I want to capture it how many
cameras are we talking about what's the
what's the team involved say with
world's largest rope swing yeah so for
that one in particular we shot that on
two different days and the first day it
was just me and another guy on camera
and then the second day is like I
realized how cool it was visually so I
brought three other camera guys so I
guess there was four guys total shooting
that as well on the second day and just
two full days of filming and essentially
four camera guys on those projects
oh well trike drifting I mean where do
you find people who can do that
barefooted these are described this to
me I mean what's your first exposure did
you didn't invent trike drifting I did
not invent track drifting so what's your
first exposure to it we always our
videos just happen from living life and
meeting the most random people so
backstory on this one which most people
don't have no idea but I get an email
from a guy in New Zealand he's like I am
super wealthy he says I love your videos
and I would like I want to fly you
first-class and meet you all year oh my
god emails that start with the phrase I
am super well yeah honestly how he
started he but he's like I can't tell
you who I am so it was a little creepy
as well okay so like okay sounds a
little sketchy so I didn't respond and
then he responds like a month later so
like he's really serious about I give my
number he calls me at four o'clock in
the morning so my okay I'm not sure
what's going on so I decided to go so he
flies me first class first time flying
first class to New Zealand just you just
me and he flew my friend as well so we
got there and then he picks us up with
his private helicopter and he owns a
website called mega upload his name is
Kim calm
why's you zealand you don't know it's
kim.com
don't know we get there you're serious
yeah this is great so it's like all
these stories we have so many stories
like this that are so like random like
how does that even happen
Kim come was like held up in his
compound well there's another story
right there which I'll tell you one
second I'm so finish this one story and
don't forget the second I promise a part
of this story so he flies as he has two
huge cars pick us up and one of the cars
says mafia and the other one says like
evil so he picks us up in those two cars
and they take us to his private
helicopter flies us and he hasn't you in
the car he wasn't in the car he had to
like gangster mob guys which were like
the nicest guys I've ever met she's like
first impressions like don't judge you
know because you don't know what you're
judging right I'm the evil mafia it was
a little scary so he takes us to is his
mansion it's the biggest mansion in New
Zealand oh yeah and then he's just like
he says I love what you guys are doing
he's like I have my private helicopter
take it out whenever you want so I
stayed there for two weeks and he never
got an email like this I don't you know
I just we'll go and didn't say that so
maybe we're making the wrong kind of
videos but just take out my helicopter
anytime you want
so we'd literally fly from one side the
island to the other side the island and
it was a seven seater so we had full
access and we would stop and we would
film how did you know how to fly a
helicopter well I didn't know how to fly
but he did his pilot did I guess is who
it was okay but it was funny like he
liked talking with him he was like I
love the villains from James Bond movies
so it was like I want to become like a
villain from the James Bond movies so
his lifestyle like the way he lives is
completely like that one night so what's
the house like I mean what does this
mansion like you were there for two
weeks
yeah it's there for two weeks he has
like 30 sports cars like he is a race
car driver like that's what he's
passionate about
he loves video games so he'd spend like
12 hours a night playing call of duty
and he was the world's best Call of Duty
player online which is like how do you
have so much money and play video games
all day but it was so nice what was the
what was the first meeting with him like
because I imagine you go into this long
room
with a executive chair facing away from
you and then it slowly turns towards you
and there's kim.com
it wasn't as dramatic as that Inspector
Gadget is what I think of it yeah but
with the cat but no he had us come in
his living room he had a gigantic table
with as much food as you can think of
like they had like 20 different waiters
that would serve you any kind of food
for each different kind of culture like
if you want an Asian food if you want to
Mexican food we had it all and it is
just like I love what you guys are doing
any sense but where was he standing and
what was he wearing and what did he look
like he looked like a normal guy who
just wearing a t-shirt it was really hot
out so it was a little sweaty and then
he was just sitting at the table and
he's like welcome to my house you know
and then he just was one of the nicest
guys I've ever met and he's like I want
to just help you guys get to the next
level because I wasn't what you guys are
doing this was two and a half years ago
maybe um I'm trying to think what his
first video we did a another video
called trike racing with trike drifting
which we just talked about was actually
the sequel to that he saw that video
he's like I loved how you had normal
speed and go to slow motion he's like
I've never seen that before so I just
love what you're doing and I love racing
so he's just like this whole islands
yours do whatever you want so we took
the helicopter we flew around we shot a
couple of videos and then he was like I
have a couple friends that do trike
drifting he's like and he showed me one
of their things like I have there their
phone and her contact he's like if you
want to do anything with them just go
out there and he says I will make sure
you get there so that was all film 2
news yeah so that that video itself was
filmed in New Zealand and he and
literally he told us that story about
these guys the day before we left so we
actually only had three hours to shoot
that video total so he just shot it at
sunset and an hour after it got dark but
yeah he was a super awesome and and
described that it's it's like it looks
like a kid big wheel but but it's got a
it's like a professional-grade big wheel
big wheel in the front it's like a tire
yeah then there's two small tires in the
back that looked like if you took all
the TP off up off a roll and just left a
bait the bear cardboard what was that I
don't even know how they made those I
know they were all super passionate
about it and they all made them in the
cell
and it was like this passe of New
Zealanders is I think there's like nine
of them that do it and they do it all
the time and in New Zealand you can
basically get away with anything as far
as the cops don't stop you like the cops
will just sit there and watch and smile
as we we would film oh yeah you were
like in a minivan shooting them behind
you you'd pull him with a rope right
yeah yeah then they would let go and
they'd be zooming down this hill and
Trent oncoming traffic would be barely
missing these guys like each side of the
oncoming train it got a little scary and
then one of the guys he's like a
longboard he's like I'm gonna longboard
down this he'll barefoot so I was like I
don't feel comfortable filming that so
if you guys want to do that go ahead and
do that so he went down and then all of
a sudden the other guy ran up and he's
like the guys down there passed out he
had a stopping he jumped out he knocked
and got everything knocked at him so he
actually had to call an ambulance but it
was just the whole thing I catch that on
camera can I refuse the film because I
was like I don't think that's a smart
idea going down a steep hill where you
can't stop barefoot does Kim calm bring
his a helicopter to take you to the
hospital at that point or is it like now
it's just a normal he's not actually
there for that part of it he was just at
his house hanging out yeah and what's
the what's the second story where he you
know he's rated by the New Zealand
authorities or like international
authorities or something yeah he's there
for that so yeah so he sits down with us
and he was like I want to start funding
every one of your videos unlimited
budget you just go out there and do your
thing so it's like I have no problem
with that whatsoever so he's like we're
gonna we're gonna fly back home and then
we'll work out all the details so we get
in the airplane we take off yeah what
did you know about him at this point
other than the fact that he's super
wealthy because before he was in the
news I didn't know anything about
megaupload or Khimki yeah I didn't know
anything about it either at the time
until I got there and he told me
essentially that makeup looked similar
to YouTube as far as people are
uploading all this stuff except for they
don't stop people from copyright stuff
essentially he's really got in trouble
for it but that's all I knew about the
website and about him but then as I
started researching I'm like there's so
much stuff about him and he used to be
this big hacker and then he changed his
life around he got back in the game and
he started giving back to society but
yeah I didn't realize he had such a kind
of a crazy
history about him and so you get back on
the plane with like a blank check it's a
no blank check yet he was gonna write it
so to speak yeah so it speaks so we flew
back to America and then I the second
wheel and I got on my phone to check
more information about him so I type in
kim.com and the first thing that pops up
is FBI raids his house for hours after
we had laughs maybe you want FBI agents
to helicopters they swarm and take over
the whole perimeter yeah he's like going
into an inner sanctum like a safe yeah
and being he's like holed up in us in us
yes they threw him in there exactly
but it kind of blew my mind I was like
we just left and all that happened like
how does that all happen right when we
leave but it was like interesting to
reading the media because they are
saying how like all these guards were
there I was like I was at that perimeter
and they only have one guard and it's
super low-key like I felt like all the
things that media was conveying was
actually not true at all because I had
just been there I had seen how it was so
I was kind of fresh a with the media's
like they're making him sound like this
awful guy when in reality I was there
and I saw all that stuff and if a
mozillian air is gonna fund everything
I'm gonna do you like them they kept him
in jail for for a month it was sad
because his wife was having twins so he
kind of missed that whole thing but
afterwards I mean he got arrested
because he had two servers that he was
running his website in America so that's
why America come could come in there
take over because it was America that
actually did that right but then they
did unjustly so they actually had to
release him and give him everything back
so he was off the hook and his criminal
record as far as that goes was
completely wiped so what happened with
your relationship so our relationship we
still talk every five or six months I
haven't asked for mine because I'm like
he's already dealing with all these
other things you know and things are
going good now where we have all these
sponsorships and stuff like that so
we're okay as far as funding ideas that
we want you know so I was okay with it
you know but it's just kind of a cool
experience see New Zealand in that way
because most people don't get that kind
of excite us well let me ask this then a
more open-ended question if that's
happened to you as a result of these
type of videos what other crazy things
and opportunities have had
open to you as a result of making the
most epic videos on YouTube I'm trying
to think I feel we get always amazing I
mean a lot of times people give a lot of
crap excuse my language but for
youtubers working with brands but for us
it gives us opportunities says
essentially do what we want so we're
gonna throw these brands down and
basically they're like we want you to
create whatever you guys can think of
we've seen what you guys have done in
the past so whatever budget you guys
need to make your ideas happen we'll
fund so essentially that's what's
happening now and I mean a good example
no other kim.com emails that was the
craziest one yeah that was definitely
craziest one so we haven't had any crazy
gnarly stories recently anyways I'm
trying to think of anything that's
happened that was just kind of
mind-blowing
but when Mountain Dew contacts you and
says hey Dale Earnhardt jr. is gonna
hang out with you guys just make any
video you want to make that's kind of
like another day at the office at this
point at this point it is and that's
exactly how that kind of went down we're
like you have his backyard do whatever
you want and you have him as the star so
we're like we'll do it so at this point
is there are there any videos that
you're just financing yourself or is it
now like well I mean there's always a
way to tie somebody and whether it's you
know the company that owns the
hoverboard right whatever yeah are you
always involving a sponsor now because
it's just such an easy fit it's a really
easy fix I I feel our content is very
brand friendly um but the same time too
though we're very and we want to do
products we're passionate about so a
couple months ago we actually I'm really
passionate about Iceland I wasn't there
a couple years ago I love the country so
like I want to tell a story of us as
filmmakers and capture that so I'm like
I want to tell that there by going to
Iceland because it's super harsh super
bad conditions and I feel if we can show
people what we have to go through to get
shots we can tell our story so that was
kind of a project that we funded
ourselves that cost a fair amount of
money we flew our helicopter guy down
there and several other film crew crew
members and we spent two weeks out there
and like awful conditions but filming
the Northern Lights and getting all
these shots we've never gotten before
and that's and that's gonna be an
hour-long film
but that's essentially things that were
passionate
about and essentially I mean we're using
YouTube to basically help us get to the
next level will always stay with you too
but we're using it as a vehicle to do
these projects that we're passionate
about it's through working with brands
and other people that we can make that
so then so this documentary since I
guess for lack of a better word is that
gonna just be distributed on your
channel yeah so we're not positive
exactly how we're gonna do I think kind
of where we're gearing is we want to
have access that everyone can watch it
regardless of the price so I think we're
gonna kind of do is something where you
pay whatever you want to pay whether it
be a penny whether it be thirty dollars
and we're not still caring about making
our money back so much is just telling
our story and inspiring other people
because essentially that's what we want
to stand for what's the favorite video
of yours that you've made so far sadly
it's usually the videos that do really
well cuz that affects how we feel about
it like you emotionally like some of the
videos that I really was passionate
about when we actually shot them they
completely flopped and then it's like
every time I watched that video or look
at that video like it hurts my heart
like what um two examples as I did a
halo video for the video game Halo and
they didn't fund it I funded it myself
and it costs I want to say fourteen
thousand dollars I flying nine people
and I was just finding to myself no
brands attacks a ton so it was the first
person shooter basically was halo in
real life the new halo video game was
gonna be coming out soon so I did that
we released it and then people didn't
like it at all and then every comment
was just like a hate comment we hate you
guys and also too was right after the
big shooting happened by Christmas time
a year two years ago so there's a lot of
violence things going on with that so we
obviously that was a very sensitive
subject so it was just bad timing as
well but it was something I put my heart
into really cared about and then it
flops so every time I think of that
video like I have a really like my heart
hurts because of that but it's still on
your channel yeah it's still on my
channel you can still go watch it can't
remember is halo in real life or
something of children leave a negative
comment yeah you still leave a negative
thought at this point yeah it doesn't
hurt so bad I'm speaking of hurt I know
that sometimes people do get hurt you oh
you got hurt in the behind-the-scenes
video we saw where the jet ski that was
I guess powering the
yeah overboard yep hit you in the back
of the head tell us about that yes uh
kind of our motto on our channel is it's
all about the shot so it's all about
putting us in dangerous situations
obviously you have to be smart about
that but in that case we're filming a
hoverboard video and I was trying to get
as close to the action as possible now
the way this hoverboard works just to
kind of but I've seen it and I'd like
for you to explain it yes so it is a
essentially a snowboard that hooks to a
hose that hooks to a jet ski or a seadoo
and you basically someone sits on the
city who pulls a throttle and then it
lifts the person on the board 30 feet up
in the air and it's shootable by water
it shoots a hydrant sized stem of water
out of the back of its snowboard it's
shooting the water that's coming out of
the jet ski normally that would propel
the jet ski shooting it through the hose
exactly so instead of air coming out of
jet ski it's actually coming out of the
board itself yeah so it's a new
invention and it just I mean it has it
actually gets released next month so
it's technically not even out in the
market yet
but yeah it's all done that way so when
the person rides on the hybrid board it
pulls a jet ski behind them so I was
trying to film the hoverboard fly over
me which also means the jet skis gonna
be falling right behind that and I are
in the water in scuba gear I'm in the
water with my underwater housing and it
flies right over me and there's so much
pressure going off that board that I get
sprayed so bad that I have no idea
what's going on and all of a sudden I
hear the jet ski right behind me and
then it completely covers me and then I
patrol over it right yeah he's being
pulled so I get clobbered in the back of
the head and this time I don't think I
have a life vest on maybe I do but I
don't think I do I want to suggest that
so I get hit and then I'm like terrified
cuz I'm like I'm gonna pass out because
it really did hurt and I'm in the open
water so I put my head down I kind of
just wait there for a second then I had
two friends I mean there's a lot of
people there watching as it was
happening so I had two friends jump in
there to make sure that I was okay and I
ended up being okay but I just kind of
one of those terrifying things as far as
what's going on and I just complete
disoriented and I and I got ran over by
a jet ski but I survived what other
videos have had things go wrong out of
all the videos we've done the
video we did on the blob more people got
hurt on that than any other video and
what that is it's a big gigantic and
floatable balloon and you jump off of a
houseboat and you have someone sit on
the end of that balloon and then the
pressure from the other person jumping
on the other end it repels them or
shoots them up in the air 50 feet that
one we had two guys jump off at the same
time to basically add pressure to the
other end and one of the guys was a
bigger guy he jumped on the guy's
collarbone and it popped the collar bone
out of his out of his neck it didn't
actually come out of his skin but I
don't do good with that stuff at all I
do give his stories about that like
squirming yeah it was very nasty like it
when it happens do you keep filming and
now you're filming the collarbone
situation yeah III pull the camera and I
was shooting this story until I got too
queasy and then we made everyone's
jumping in though it's not like I'm
filming and everyone's laughing and
party and still like people are jumping
in pulling them out and I'm filming it
just to capture that story they pull him
he's okay we obviously take a 20-minute
break and make sure to figure out what
we can do to fix this problem then we
realize don't jump and everyone be
holding hands and have your arms
actually interlocked and what happens to
the guy with the collarbone he's leaves
tired he's fired no so he was like I'll
be okay we doing bunch of painkillers
and then we got a boat and then we sent
him to get fixed so he's fine get a
rubber mallet and just kind of tap on
him but yeah that happened a girl jumped
off the cliff while we were there
filming and her she bruised her broke
her collarbone we had one girl spitting
out blood from just the impact of the
water oh my and then I was running
across the deck of the bow because the
Sun was setting and the lighting was
really pretty sari is trying to hurry
and then I land on the water I slipped
so I ran into the side of the boat and
then I broke my toe stupid out of all
the things I do that's where I break it
so so okay this one raises a couple of
questions at this point with the size of
your operation do you like what is the
what is the arrangement with the people
who come and do this like was there is
some sort of insurance policy that
covers everybody is there an on-site
doctor right
great question so originally starting
off we didn't know what we were doing we
were just going out there with our
friends having fun now as it's gotten
bigger you have to take a lot more
precautions so the precautions that we
take is we actually have insurance that
covers everyone that's there if
something does go wrong whether it be a
death as far as like making sure
everyone's protected we're protected or
if they're her we have it basically
we'll cover them as far as hospital
bills and stuff like that everyone signs
a release form everyone signs a waiver
basically saying we're okay if we do get
hurt we're aware of what we're doing and
then depending on the project we'll pay
the people or will not pay the people
and that just depends on if it's a
branded thing or if it's not branding
the thing if it's not Brandon thing we
just make sure it's a really awesome
essentially party where everyone has a
really good experience and we cover
everyone's cost as far as that goes
right so it's pretty easy to get people
to show up yeah yeah we just hold a big
thing and I mean we could get thousands
of people but usually it's kind of
invited only we just did something in
San Francisco actually where you made a
gigantic slip and slide down the streets
of San Francisco and then I just did an
Instagram and Twitter post saying hey
all my fans you guys are invited the
first hundred people that sign up get
all access so just different ways that
we're doing it now you rarely
participate in any of those dots I mean
you're you're directing and shooting
right correct you're not it you're not a
dive in kind of a guy know so I thought
I broke my back in high school and I was
told I would never be able I did a
snowboard and I was told I was never be
able to snowboard again what was the was
this story yeah it was a jump I was
trying it was the last day of the
snowboard season my goal originally was
to be a cross-country track runner like
that was what I plan on doing with my
life so that happened and that obviously
changed things pretty dramatically I was
in bed for three months I had a metal
back brace did you go off a jump and
land oh no I went off the jump it was
probably about a 70 foot jump and I
didn't clear the jump so you're supposed
to land on a downslope I landed flat so
it'd be like jumping off of a two-story
house and then just landing straight
somebody back my sorry I'm hiccuping but
my back it actually my vertebrae squish
so it's an l2 compression fracture is
the technical jargon did you land on
your butt no I landed on my feet but my
vertebrae literally squid
from the impact I'm just falling too
high so but you technically landed it I
technically landed we're gonna roll a
couple of times and that's a problem
with cameras like we had the camera so I
got it all on film like oh really you're
always pushing things on your on a film
but I think that makes it so I'm very
cautious now because I know people are
gonna push themselves more but I'm like
I'll say I don't think you should be
doing this like I make sure I'm
constantly asking people do you feel
comfortable at this cuz I don't want
anyone hurt so at this point and you
break something else too though
yeah then a couple months well after I
was able to walk again and actually I
got back and started snowboarding again
right back a couple of weeks later I
break my leg and this time I bone
actually shot out my leg in my leg was
just flapping laughter where was it it
was at the shin or the femur I was a
femur you broke your femur this part of
the body right no I never took the land
anatomy classes you broke like the tibia
yeah the TB or whatever fancy named you
guys call it how did you break that one
I was at a snowboard camp and I was
jumping on that trampoline that's
supposed to train you and I over jumped
and landed on the spring landing on the
spring it instantly broke the bone out
and then I flew off the trampoline and
landed on the ground with my leg
flopping back and forth I got that all
on video as well really so do these just
like videos that you watch just to
yourself or know in high school I mean
that's kind of a made me learn how to
edit is I would always go out there and
make snowboarding videos with my friends
and then I'd self taught myself how to
edit because I wanted to show my friends
so we're always going out there filming
each other snowboarding and I think
that's kind of what got me in the whole
extreme sport kind of genre that we are
in now is is this all started I mean it
started before high school but that's
when I started pushing it so it's you're
it was a personal interest but then the
injuries kind of sidelined you a little
bit yeah they sidelined me a little bit
and I mean the truth of the matter is
half the things I film I'm actually
afraid of so I am absolutely terrified
of heights but half of our videos deal
with Heights
but that's why for me it's a challenge I
feel intrigued by it so I pushed my
selves and I faced my fears even though
I'm not doing a lot of these things
myself I push myself as far as just
challenging myself to do things I'm
afraid of I leaned over the cliff edge
and other things like that so did you
grow up and like a stunt family
no worse no fourth family no I grew up
as just like a Boy Scout doing my thing
Eagle you know and I grew up making Lego
movies with my siblings like that's kind
of what got me in the whole video we're
all doing motion stop-motion lego movies
and music videos with my siblings and
where was this this was an Oregon I'm
from Portland Oregon that's where I grew
up that's where I was raised three other
siblings and I just take them and we
make Lego movies together in music
videos together and just stupid random
ninja movies together and I just always
loved it I mean I was taking my parents
cameras and then I'd probably ruined
three or four of my parents cameras but
they've always been so supportive NYU
and why don't you ruin a camera we're
always making a stop-motion I know well
push the push the shutter too hard well
this is when VHS existed so the tapes
would get clan or cramped in there and
just ruin the whole cameras okay there's
old-school stuff not digital at all but
but that is kind of the knack that
didn't followed you into snowboarding
yep just carry all crumpled together it
is it's all one no matter what you're
doing and then I started doing wedding
video so just I've gone through a couple
different phases you know but I just I'm
always learning different aspects as far
as I love that I always love it when I
hear that somebody who's doing what
you're doing now made a wedding video we
made a wedding video aha there's this
thing that there are people out there
who can say things like yeah our wedding
video was made by Devin sue it's like at
the time you know it was just Devin no
yeah Devin's got a camera he's gonna do
this there's just something about people
being able to say that after the fact
Maria Matthews is the only person who
can say that they have a rhettandlink
winning I did a good job on that with
the montage the dance montage oh yeah
that was so so black and white
and I did a lot of fades no no Devin
glidecam or anything like that then now
I know you went on a Mormon mission so
you yeah you grew up Mormon
a honker up LDS or Mormon okay went to
Jamaica
yeah I went to Jamaica you guys know
your facts
impressed but yeah I went to Jamaica for
two years so right after high school
three months after high school I got a
mission call to go for our church and
basically represent them and we went to
Jamaica I went to Jamaica for two years
very easy decision for you like
automatic yeah I've always known I'm
going on a mission yeah I've always knew
because I just love working with people
talking to people I always knew I wanted
to do it it's not required that you do
it in our church but I knew it was
something that I wanted to do so I sent
out my paper saying I would love to go
on a mission and that's when they asked
me to go to Jamaica they're like you're
needed in Jamaica to serve the people
there so I spent basically two years
serving the people as far as community
service and then also teaching them
about Jesus and that's what I did and
for me it was awesome because I got to
see a whole new experience as far as
culture and I feel everything I do now
is tied right back and do that because
we travel all around the world and we're
constantly meeting different people so
it just it's been really cool as far as
balancing me that way do you wear a
black tie white shirt and name tag yeah
you wear the whole I mean now oh no no
not at all you know wearing it right now
but right now I'll wear a white shirt
and a tie when I go to church on it that
day but no name tags but yeah that's the
church standards as far as the
missionaries go so when people see that
they know as far as okay those guys are
the the Mormon of the LDS missionary you
know is Jamaica dangerous is there a
dangerous side of that that you kind of
interfaced with as a missionary yeah
it's actually the at the time anyways it
was the third most dangerous country per
capita so I mean I was on buses where
the bus got hijacked I was walking down
the street with people seeing them like
pluck guns I saw a guy get killed as far
as get shot and we ran through gun
battles so it was like a third world
full experience um there was time heaven
when the bus got hijacked how did you
get out of that one um trying to
remember exact cause we were sitting
near the front and then all of a sudden
this guy pulls out this huge machete
huge knife then he holds this lady with
all her earrings and stuff and pulls a
knife right up to her neck and then he
starts taking everything from everybody
everyone just basically was giving
everything off and anyway
than the exit of the back of the bus did
you give anything up I I wasn't asked to
give anything up and we were the front
of the bus so we weren't like face to
face with the guy but it was kind of one
of those experiences where you're like
what are you gonna do and that kind of
experience and it was definitely very
traumatic I realized early on because I
died right my mom every every week and I
told her about a couple of those stories
and then she got like really terrified
so I was like you can't tell her
everything that's going on in Jamaica
because you don't want to scare everyone
back home but it was I mean I felt safe
still there I mean I wouldn't have gone
there if I didn't feel safe with what we
were doing and the people there was
awesome because they loved the
missionaries so they would take care of
us you know and people were very
respectful as far as that goes
is your faith still a large component of
your life now yeah I mean I honestly
feel with all the videos that we do I
try and stay true to who I am you know
and it's about inspiring people
it's about being positive having
uplifting messages so I mean and the one
of the things we do is like we don't
swear we don't smoke we don't drink so
in our videos and it's also about
dressing modest as well so in our videos
you'll notice that we don't swear we
don't drink we're not having girls
completely nude or anything like that
you know like we're very as far as
conservative as far as that stuff goes
but I wanted to hit and honestly I
filled in your nude it really hurts
hitting that water and Oh believe me I
think one person actually did go down
dude just so he could say he did it but
we didn't capture that for the video
different story but an honestly - I feel
it's actually by doing that it's worked
to our advantage because it's made our
video super family-friendly almost kind
of like a Disney of YouTube so all
audience can share it and it's not just
an older audience or a more mature
audience and also - because there's not
a lot of dialogue in our videos it's
also made it very international so a lot
and sharing our national so I feel it's
really helped us as far as all that
stuff goes by living our faith mm-hmm
now we've we've talked to Shea kind of
told us about his mission which was
similar and that he was in a Caribbean
country wasn't where did he go he went
somewhere that they also spoke English
and then some similar uh-huh things
happened to him but we also talked with
Lindsey mm-hmm
who tell us a little bit about your
your history with Lindsey Stirling yeah
guys this podcast that you guys did with
her so I heard her her whole little
shenanigans but yeah I was I was
actually living in Hawaii at the time
and someone showed me one of her videos
from America's Got Talent and I was all
about finding interesting people because
interesting people people want to watch
on YouTube now you are in Hawaii just to
connect the dots you went to BYU after
your mission but as you said earlier you
dropped out in order to be a youtuber
right yeah so that happened as far as
the bike jump video and then I got an
opportunity to go to Hawaii for a year
and do a documentary so it's basically I
moved to Hawaii to do that documentary
and then I had a lot of free time so I
started doing YouTube videos constantly
to kill time essentially because their
budget actually ran out so it's like I
just dropped out of school they had no
budget so that's when I decided I'm just
gonna go for the YouTube thing because
I'm already here in Hawaii and I can't
go back because I just gave up
everything else so I started doing
videos there in Hawaii after that bike
jump video and you made some that really
popped that really built your channel
after yeah so after that I did that
another video is a water reservoir that
we snuck into wasn't drinking water but
we did a big slip and slide we did that
Biel then exploded then we kept on doing
videos that was there it was a pond but
all the whole thing was just black yeah
yep that was a tarp holding water so
yeah we did that video just exploded
again we got all this commercial work
from it as well so it just like we just
kept trying to ride the wave and then I
started putting on a video every other
week and then I started doing a video
every week and then that's what I just
truly took off when you saw this amazing
violinist on America's Got Talent and
what happened so I saw that and at that
time the piano guys are you guys
familiar with them yeah so they
contacted me and they were like we see
what you're doing on YouTube we want to
try this as well we'd love to fly you
down to Utah cuz that's where we're
based out of and that's where I was
going to school the time you come to our
mansion with all our sports I'm evil
winters mafia the other says piano they
were a little bit smaller humble
beginnings this had a piano for those
guys but I was like I'm gonna go into
Utah I know that's where Lindsay's bass
because she was actually going to BYU as
well which we never met when I was going
to BYU cuz she was going on her mission
at the time when I was going to school
there
so I contacted Lindsay I'm like I'm
shooting the piano guys this day and I
have one free day I love to shoot a
video on you it was not gonna cost you
anything and then I gotta put it on my
channel and then you essentially get all
the iTunes sales from that so she's like
that sounds good let me think about it
essentially but and then she came back
to me she's like I just checked out your
channel and she's like I'd love to do
something with you so I was really
excited about it
so I did the piano guys and then we shot
all night so after we got done shooting
I went straight to Lindsay Stiles picked
her up and then we spent all day filming
her video which was a four video called
spontaneous me put that on my channel
and then it literally the same thing
happened as far as it took off people
had never seen a girl dancing and
playing violin right so once that took
on you put the word epic in the title
epic violin girl you have to have epic
because that people think is epic and
they click on it there was no faking
people out there so yeah we did that
video with Lindsay and then we just
started talking back and forth I mean it
was the whole long-distance thing as far
as just beat we were just friends but
talking back and forth on Facebook and
then I had another opportunity to go
back to Utah a couple weeks later so I
went back there and we shot another
video together and we just became best
friends and then a couple months later
we started dating as well and then I
moved back from Hawaii to Utah and then
we ended up dating for I want to say
around 16 months give or take I'm not
sure what she told you guys but
somewhere around that general area yeah
and then I've been in the whole YouTube
scene for about a year at this time and
then essentially I think I shot the
first 23 videos on our YouTube channel
and then wherever I went I'd take her
with me so for example New Zealand we
just talked about that was who I
actually took with me it was Lindsey
Stirling and we knew that so we're like
kim.com so makes it even more interest
oh man but we were like we're going to
New Zealand so let's do a Lord of the
Rings medley so we took this guy's
helicopter that's where that was yeah so
as film in New Zealand it's like that's
where the movie takes place so we ride
in the helicopter we see a pretty spot
and then he land the helicopter Lindsay
would get out and then I'd film all
these aerial shots from Kim comms
helicopter so when you watch the
you're like okay that's kim.com
financing Lindsey Stirling now the
description at the bottom is special
thanks to Kim comm for making this
happen arguably you launched Lindsey's
career I mean it's one thing to be on
America's Got Talent and she was she's
fabulous but it was that video which
really set things off I mean in the wake
of America's Got Talent
uh-huh that changed the trajectory of
her entire career and I mean that's what
she said as well did you do the same
thing for the yo-yo guy did you launch
his career well I don't know about
launched his career it definitely got
his name out there in different ways I'm
not sure exactly what he's doing right
now was um probably yo-yoing probably
yelling let's be honest because he was
like the yo-yo champion but he started
getting a lot of jobs as well and I
honestly I feel for every one that we
get to work with I mean I think that's
kind of what our YouTube channel is it's
like America's Got Talent but on YouTube
on steroids as far as we're trying to
find people with weird cool hidden
talents and then essentially launching
them we did a video on Assassin's Creed
meets parkour is what it's called yeah I
think it has 36 million views your most
viewed video our most viewed video but
it's the same story the guy I had do it
I just heard that he was a local guy
that did parkour so I contacted him and
he did construction work so I'm like I'm
doing this video on Assassin's Creed I
love for you to be in it and this was I
wasn't doing this with the video game
company I just doing it because I like
the video game I was like it'd be cool
to do this in real life so he said he'd
be down so he did it for free we spent
seven different evenings filming it
launch the video and he didn't have a
YouTube channel at the time so he
created one just so we could send
subscribers over there and I think it
made him get like 80,000 subscribers and
then all of a sudden all these big TV
shows started contacting them Disney
actually did a commercial featuring him
so all of a sudden he actually quit his
construction job and then he's been
doing stunt work full-time since we did
that video so it's just been really cool
seeing that community I feel that's
what's so great about the YouTube
YouTube community is about everyone
working together building off of each
other's strengths then everyone benefits
together it's a beautiful thing I mean
what can you do for us no I mean you
make Carl jump off of something yes
right
yeah he
to do at that what did he jump off of
home swing saying he did the biggest
rope swing they've done yet which was a
400 foot rope swing and he can't don't
ask us to do there that won't figure out
something though you guys have your
dancing zebra though we still do though
you know you know what we can even get
in that thing
zebra on the ropes way yeah we're not in
it we can take credit make people think
we are now so in and to finish the the
story on Lindsey - I mean she her
analysis of your relationship was that
you guys both love the same types of
things and that kind of you were kind of
memorial eyes that there wasn't maybe
this wasn't a love thing that was gonna
last forever
yeah so we were both definitely very
passionate about creating videos and we
definitely loved each other at the time
or at least I thought we did you never
know doubt is but yeah we got and we got
along so well like we were best friends
me and Lindsey and we did everything
together we're shooting all these videos
and creating all this content and at the
time - like I'd only been doing it a
year so it was still new to me as far as
exciting so we were learning together we
were growing together and we were
helping each other together and then
over time like she got so busy with
everything that was happening not that
works ever more important but it's just
trying to figure out balance with
everything and then I was traveling
everywhere and we just thought I mean it
wasn't the best fit for everything that
was going on well when you have a Mormon
faith I mean there's a lot at stake you
got to make sure that you're dating the
right person cuz when you marry em it's
forever yeah exactly you just you're
forever you populate a planet this is
this is a big deal right yeah cuz we
believe you when you're married is for
time and all eternity so I mean where we
stay as far away from divorce obviously
there's certain reasons when you have to
have divorce but we we believe you get
married and forever you make it work you
figure out how to best get along and
we're like this isn't just testing the
waters kind of thing yeah this is a
forever thing so it's like we wanted to
make sure and it was like we we dated
for a while and it just wasn't the best
fit for us you know like it's hard to
have two very passionate people that are
doing two different things make it work
as kind of what I've realized is I've
done the whole dating scene you know and
try to figure that out but yeah it was a
learning process and I mean I still look
at Lindsey is one of my best
friends and we've gone our own separate
ways and done our own things you know
but it's been really exciting seeing
what Lindsey's going out there and
creating and and changing the world in
our own unique ways you know it's been
exciting knowing that I had a hand and
making that happen you know and seeing
that process unfold all right so what
about the dating life now which is on
the internet as well more than with you
and Lindsay right
tell us about Hayley so this is a
sensitive subject
oh really no it's all good that we would
what this is the uncut unedited I'm
rated very that's right that's what a
near biscuit is yeah near biscuit we're
all about that but yeah we're just we're
still trying to figure it out as well
Haley's amazing she's an amazing
musician and it's just the same thing
though it's just figuring so she's one
of three Gardiner sisters yeah three
garner sisters they're a YouTube channel
as well I met Haley on a our flyboard
video which was similar to the hybrid
board video when Hawaii she came to my
shoot and we just same thing we became
really good friends and then I heard she
had a YouTube channel so I was like let
me check out your guys YouTube channel
because it wasn't huge what it was just
doing okay I checked it out I like these
girls are amazingly talented so I
contacted him and like I sat down with
them and I was because I'm all about
giving back and helping people because
everyone benefits that way so I kind of
told them the secrets I knew about
YouTube as far as how to grow and what
the best ways I saw that happened for
Lindsay because it was similar thing as
far as musician musician and then how
they could actually monetize by selling
iTunes cover songs so I kind of went
over that with them and then they
started doing that and I started
shooting their videos and then me and
Haley fell in love essentially is what
happened and then that's kind of how
it's been with that and I mean right now
though we're not together and we're just
trying to figure out lie because once
again it goes back to that same thing as
far as two passionate people trying to
figure it out because you go in
different directions you know so okay so
I'm not gonna say I sense a pattern here
but you come in we've talked about two
girls yes but do you think that this is
just related to you you've stated in
other places that you'd like to stay
busy I mean all I have to do is knowing
what we know about YouTube you can look
at your channel and know that you're
busy not to mention the fact that you're
not making you know videos and once 2d
every single day and you're all over the
world it does that make it difficult to
have a long term relationship yeah well
there's a couple different things I
guess is this happens with each of the
relationships in Hayley's case she's
going to school at BYU Hawaii in Hawaii
and we've been separated for the last
five months so I mean I've had to keep
myself busy but it's like when we're in
the same place together we make sure we
spend time together you know that so
it's not an issue of that I feel it can
work but I just do to the circumstances
that we've been put in as far as she's
been gone for the last five or six
months we've been FaceTime and
everything every day but it does get
really hard it does make things
complicated the good thing now though is
I have a team of other people that I
trust as far as team Supertramp is what
we call I guess our group of filmmakers
where I can send them out so I can be
home a lot of the time instead of work
and whatnot right so but yeah I just
figuring out that bow so it's kind of on
you you're on a hiatus right now but
maybe when she finishes up who knows
what yeah who knows what what happens I
think the world of her and she is my
best friend yeah okay well just keep us
posted on that let's let's bring you
back full circle I you know at the
beginning of talked about how there's an
there's a vibe to your videos that goes
beyond what I'm seeing is awesome and
scary and an amazing stunt there's a
tone of just exuberance like everybody's
having fun everybody's happy one of the
things that run I discussed when we re
watch the videos in prep was the choices
of who you show when in the video goes a
long way to make it something much more
than what you would think it would have
to be to be a viral video mm-hmm it
you're not just shooting an amazing
hoverboard and you're not really
explaining how it works
who because who you know there's a whole
channel that could be devoted to that
but you're not even just showing the
amazing thing that happens in the air or
while this is swinging or whatever the
case may be but only the people who
pushes yeah you're seeing the reactions
I mean tell us your philosophy there
yeah so my philosophy there I'm gonna
tell a quick little story really fast
Phil it explains our philosophy maybe a
year ago I give this email from this guy
in Morocco and he was like I have never
been so depressed in my life and finally
one day I decided I was gonna end my
life so he said it was like 4 o'clock in
the morning and he got everything to
basically slit his wrists and end his
life and he said he was 100% committed
to killing himself and he said right
before he did that he said he got this
thought to go back on my YouTube channel
and watch through the videos because he
wanted to be reminded what he would be
missing if he wasn't alive and he said
by watching those videos it was like it
created all these experiences for them
even though he had never had them but it
made him realize how amazing life is and
the people that are in life and that's
kind of I I feel our philosophy with
what we do is we want to show people how
amazing the world is and it's not about
the hoverboard it's about the people and
the experience with the hoverboard that
I mean I feel with the media especially
it's all about negative this and that
and how the world's falling apart but at
the same time we don't see all the
positive things because that isn't news
quote-unquote but it's like the way we
look at it is show people how amazing
the world is the people around it put
them in these amazing experiences and
then inspire them to show then life can
be great get outside get your friends
together have fun and do what you love
to do and if you break a collarbone cut
that out cut it out but it always makes
it cut like it's nothing behind the
scenes but yeah I said it beaches right
yes well you know you get this feeling I
remember I don't know specifically what
video was but I do remember the first
time I watched one of your videos and
you and I got the SIS I wanted to be
there right that I was like who are
these people and why are they having
such a good time I mean I know that this
awesome thing is happening but it's just
like this community that she wanted that
you want to be a part of and they're all
beautiful so where do you find these
beautiful people that you put in your
your videos yeah that's a great question
people are always like why you always
just have such pretty friends I mean
that's not true because I have all kinds
of friends and everything else
I'm trying to think of the right way but
yeah we just invite our friends that we
feel are photogenic okay we'll have
other people that aren't photogenic
don't get me wrong but we obviously yeah
put them in
but yeah we just like showing everything
but we I mean our videos they do have
big people they have little people and
generally though it's who's ever in that
area is who we capture so for example
San Francisco we had people of all
different races colors different sizes
and we featured all of them so it just
depends on what area what demographic
we're in is - we feature and we have no
problem featuring anyone as far as any
of that stuff people who are willing to
hang out on the edge of a cliff tend to
look a certain way and be you know so
it's you get you take what you can get
you know well another thing - and I
think this plays right along it with why
everything that you do is so sponsor
friendly but you do also get the sense
that whatever these people are into I'm
going to buy you know I'm saying it's
just like the music is great what
they're doing is fun they look great
oh they're drinking them out and do I
want to think about and do I mean it
seems like it's just ready-made yeah for
first sponsorship and I would also think
that it would be the kind of thing that
you would your door would be getting
knocked down to go direct commercials is
that happening yeah it's happening
constantly and a lot of people say like
how do you get started doing commercial
work and what I tell them is when we
started I was just featuring my friends
clothing company the time it was a
viewer aid they were no one knew about
him so I was like I want to feature your
guys's product don't pay me anything but
what will happen is other clothing
companies that are much bigger we'll see
hey he did this with the VA it has 14
million views what can you do with us
you know right now we're about to do a
big video with champion clothing company
you know and we have all these other
sponsorships we just did something with
speed stick deodorant and that's
actually a zip line through Panama City
like the city itself to base jump so
they're seeing our videos were like hey
Devon did this sponsorship here even
though it was a small one at the time
they're seeing that so now they want us
to do bigger and better things so I mean
that's kind of how its evolved with all
that but they saw that we were proving
ourselves with other people okay so
lastly tell us what's the biggest idea
that you haven't been able to do yet but
that you want to pull off one day
one of the ideas we're gonna do sooner
than later it's not crazy crazy crazy
extreme but everyone absolutely loves
our rope swinging videos so the first
one we did was through an arts 200 feet
the follow-up was 400 feet the next one
I want to do because I'm always trying
to think what can we do that's gonna be
bigger and better than the last one that
will get people reason to share it so
we're like I want to do a rope swing
through a gigantic city like it'll
completely change the look so it
basically gonna be super or spider-man
in real life through a city's kind of
the next big thing that I want to do and
obviously getting permits and all that
stuff it's very hard so I'll probably
have to do it in a foreign country but
that's kind of the next big thing that
we're gonna do or is still working out
the details with that but you you're
actually laying the groundwork for it
the initial groundwork is just figuring
out the right sponsorship because I feel
we have so many opportunities with
different sponsors but it's like who's
gonna be the best fit right that's gonna
let us tell a story that we want to tell
with this because we're not gonna
personally be able to close off all the
roads get all the bills and stuff like
that like we will have to have a sponsor
to do so we're trying to figure out the
best sponsor for that well listen man
we'll be excited to see whatever you
come out with next and it's been cool to
hang out here so thanks for the time
yeah thank you guys guys rock stars over
and out
[Music]
and there you have it our ear biscuit
with Devin Supertramp you know I think
after having that conversation with him
we have significantly increased our
chances of collaborating and that sounds
exciting but there's you know you got to
count the cost of a thing such as this
like it the cost could be our lives
right so we must need to pull back on
that it's no ordinary collaboration I
mean this is not like some vlogger who's
like hey I'll come be on your GMM or you
can come to my bedroom and make a video
with me well you know you know what I
mean not that kind of video but the kind
of video that bloggers making their
bedroom like a vlog this is like we're
gonna hook you up to something that well
he did it shaycarl he didn't went out
there and I don't know if it was the
world's largest rope swing I think it
was it was one of those that he actually
did that the interesting thing I mean
sometimes when like in just in
conversation with friends things like
bungee jumping or skydiving comes up
Nick asked me this the other day when we
went when we were going camping he was
like we were talking my skydiving he was
like would you ever go skydiving and I
said well for a video I might but I
wouldn't do it just for the fun of it
but I would do it I might do it if we
were making a video I mean that's I
think that's the only scenario where I
would do something if we were going to
do it we would make it a video so it's
sort of I mean the sort of answers
itself
I mean it's will will you do it I mean
I'm the one who's scared of heights I'm
very scared of heights
I don't like ropes courses I don't even
like standing up being the tall person
that I am but Nick Nick did skydiving
just to do skydiving there's plenty of
people to do that they don't but it has
to take me making a video and creating
something in order to put me over the
edge literally do it tandem like a few
of us together is that how you do it the
first no because the implication is that
the one on the back of the tandem knows
what they're doing
yeah and I don't think he came out three
tandem how about me and you but then
there's a guy behind me triple up
is that can you do that so you want to
make it even I just want to make it a
funny video make this the the human glob
underneath the parachute he as heavy as
possible that doesn't sound smart you
just get a bigger parachute the thing
that I just got a trip out of Devon
talking about how I assumed that these
were like stuntmen and like their safety
officers around and things like that and
it it is more of this let's just get a
group of friends who are willing to do
these things and have some what you
gotta remember its YouTube yeah you you
make these assumptions about it but you
gotta remember this guy is it looks so
high you see he's still a youtuber you
know and that's what that's what I love
about it I mean I don't love the fact
that you know there's there's not a team
of safety officers however but let you
know it is getting to that point like
you said that you know he's doing these
big branded projects and that kind of
thing so it's gotta be more like a
traditional film shoot or whatever when
I worked for IBM there was a man named
Rick whose full-time job was Safety
Officer and this is that it like it's
just a corporation you know like like
paper cut
Rick polling was his name he was like he
kind of was like a swarthy sailor type
guy he had like white hair and a white
beard like don't lift the water cooler
by yourself I don't understand what he
he oversaw the safety features of the
manufacturing facility so it does make a
little more sense but he also designed
like the offices and to make sure that I
don't know people didn't run into walls
slam their hands and laptops and he had
the greatest sense of humor like yes
like a swarthy sailor he looked and
sounded like you can hurt your finger on
that little mouse that the IBM ThinkPads
had in the middle of it that little nub
although you can dis lit right nipple
you can you can dislocate a digit on
that red nipple I've never touched the
red nipple stay away from that thing
shout-out to Rick poling I missed that
guy I hope he's he's probably still
alive he's so safe right Morty he's not
what if he's not well this would be true
I don't know you guys should tweet at
Devon I mean you can try to track down
Rick polling too I think that's that's
fine take it or leave it but definitely
tweet at Devon let him know what you
think of his ear biscuit is
handle is Devin Supertramp de VI n
Supertramp so let them know what you
think hashtag ear biscuits on that and
we will be rope swinging back your way
drifting into another death-defying ear
biscuit next Friday yes
happens every week and if we do the
Devon collaboration then we'll will
obviously let you know because that's
the only reason we're gonna be doing it
is so that you can watch it and laugh at
us I think we're gonna be put in in post
oh we're gonna be put it in into post
we're gonna be put into one of his
videos in post okay I'm not gonna
actually be there a lot of a lot of
rotoscoping okay see you next week
[Music]
[Music]